[Musique]
avec ces sondages en hausse eric zemmour
prend t-il à la droite ou aux arènes
alors que les analyses sur le polémiste
s'emballe nous allons comme toujours
faire un pas de côté en nous intéressant
aux fondements de son discours afin de
mieux comprendre qu'il séduit pourquoi
et avec quelles limites un exercice que
nous ferons avec véronique res houleux
qui passera au crible l'engouement pour
zemmour sur les réseaux sociaux et tout
de suite christophe de voogd spécialiste
de rhétorique et des idées politiques
ainsi que sylvain crépon politologue
spécialiste de l'électorat et rennes qui
se trouve cette rentrée face à un drôle
de discours marine le pen elle a un
socle très très solide mais vous avez vu
elle a déjà perdu cinq points dans les
sondages elle était à 26 allées déclic à
21 je pense que le l'échec aux
régionales
a été un très mauvais coup pour elle et
tout le monde a compris warren qu'elle
ne gagnera jamais ça ressemble un
message aux électeurs de marine le pen
même si le style de son discours ne
marche pas mais alors pas du tout sur
les plates bandes de la candidate et
rennes à la fin du livre dans la
conclusion il est quasi si vous comparez
pas à jeanne d'arc bonaparte ou de
gaulle
non mais vous avez bien fait
je ne compare pas
je prends un exemple vous savez c'est
pas la même chose je ne comparerai
jamais à bonaparte qui pour moi le plus
grand personnage de l'histoire de france
je suis un à côté de lui et nous sommes
tous des nains à côté lui donc je ne me
comparerais pas en revanche je m'inspire
je me suis toujours comporté comme ça
quand j'écrivais des livres je
m'inspirais des plus grands écrivains je
passais des jours et des semaines avec
chateaubriand balzac je les lisais tête
rageuse m'imprégner de cela sylvain
crépon bonjour alors ce qui nous a
frappés dans cet extrait assez la somme
des références littéraires historiques
alors c'est du style certes mais le
style on le sait c'est essentiel et ce
style parle-t-il aux électeurs indiens
de marine le pen nothing dean des liens
de plus en plus qu'il doute d'elle comme
on vient entendre alors je pense que
c'est pas les références en tant que tel
qui parle aux électeurs de marine le pen
et je pense que c'est plus comme
s'inscrivant dans l'histoire dans la
culture dans le génie français lui aussi
un tout le temps ce terme à la bouche et
donc je pense qu'il veut montrer que par
là il ya un discours qui se veut
enracinée et là on est vraiment quand
dans quelque chose on en reparlera sans
doute tout à l'heure mais qui est dans
une problématique une thématique est
propre à l'extrême droite qui est celle
de l'enracinement et eric zemmour c'est
quelqu'un qui veut se montrer sans cesse
enracinée et il veut montrer qu'il parle
de quelque part qui ne parlent d'un
point de vue qu'il parle d'une histoire
et qu'il n'est pas une sorte d'électron
libre sur un nul face au néant comme il
le dit par toutes ces lectures tout ce
génie français cela dit c'est vrai qu'on
se souvient effectivement avec le bon
jean marie le pen était quelqu'un de
très cultivé qui citait volontiers
jeunes d'art alors on se demande s'ils
cherchent à renouer avec cette veine
parce que marine le pen elle est
beaucoup moins dans ces citations ses
références être rapidement marine le pen
c'est une politicienne de sa génération
j'ai envie de dire à l'aîné avec la
télévision la vidéo elle a pris ensuite
le cleee des réseaux sociaux on a envie
de dire comme les électeurs aussi parce
que les électeurs les intimide pas
toutes ces références enfin c'est
maintenant je pense pas que ça les anti
mines je pense qu'au contraire ça
légitime zemmour comme un personnage une
sorte j'en veux dire c'est très ambiguë
mais c'est en même temps j'en reviens
toujours à ça c'est une problématique
propres à l'extrême droite c'est à dire
c'est une forme d'intellectualisme anti
intellectualiste
faire élite avec ce genre de disque bien
sûr bien sûr mais il prend bien soin à
chaque fois de contrecarrer ces
références extrêmement savante avec ses
origines populaires
avec bon je vais parler aux vrais gens
je les connais je n'ai pas peur d'aller
tout en critiquant les élites qui sont
complètement je comprends bien il est
quand même plus dans cet enracinement du
moins ils cherchent à être plus dense
attend massivement une extrême droite
que marine le pen pour lui beaucoup plus
beaucoup de façon beaucoup plus assumer
absolument christophe devals d'un mort
justement sur l' usage qui fait ses
références historiques m'écoutais je
suis partage très largement cette
analyse je pète une petite nuance sur
sur leurs racines manque est un thème
aussi que j'utilise énormément le
général de gaulle et je rappelle le
début des mémoires d'espoir ou par
exemple aussi la philosophe simone weil
c'est en effet un thème de l'extrême
droite mais mais pas que comme on dit
aujourd'hui
la référence aux cas la culture
française est aussi quelque chose ou
chateaubriand c'est pas l'extrême droite
et même jeanne d'arc ce n'est pas
l'extrême droite parce qu'elle jeanne
d'arc public n ont jamais l'oublier bien
sûr c'est pas des références électro
mais c'est beaucoup dralha rassasie soit
français c'est ça mais c'est plutôt le
skill zemmour l âge tout à fait d'accord
avec vous c'est plutôt un style en effet
des grands tribuns on va dire
intellectuelle dans la veine
intellectualisant tu es historicisante
c'est très important parce que je crois
que la grande référence en fait de
zemmour c'est toujours l'histoire et on
y reviendra sans doute ce par quoi il se
distingue ce par quoi il brille c'est
par ses références historiques qui
mettent des autres très mal à l'aise
lorsque très intéressant d'ailleurs ce
mot je suis historien il se trouve que
il n'a pas toujours raison mais comme il
est plus fort que les autres d autres
sont incapables de le contrer
mais cette idée de 2,2 zemmour qui prend
la place de l'open je crois que c'est
l'extrême vous avez montré au début
quand il dit elle peut pas gagner et ça
ne fait ça s'adresse à l'électorat de
marine le pen choix ça va au delà c'est
l'idée je vais me battre des cartes et
si cette thèse comme on dit en
rhétorique si cette thèse que marine le
pen ne peut pas gagner il le dit de
façon très convaincante ayew c'est
secret de polichinelle 1 il dit façon
terrifiante dévastatrice nucléaire pour
elle et si ça ça rentre dans l'opinion
sa rebat les cartes de la présidentielle
rebat les cartes un parmi les références
justement il ya une très contestée c'est
maréchal pétain alors on rappelle
qu'eric zemmour avait affirmé qu'il
avait sauvé des juifs qu'une plainte
avait été déposée mais que des bus 2021
le polémiste a été relaxé à leur faim
tant sur le fond car le tribunal a
considéré que dans ses propos il y avait
bien du révisionnisme hommes en raison
d'un contexte dans le débat sur la syrie
cela dit ces derniers temps quand eric
zemmour parle du maréchal pétain c'est
aussi pour le renvoyer au nez de ses
adversaires comme ici vous m'avez traité
à la télévision pas en face de moi mais
ailleurs deux pétainisme y est c'est
très intéressant parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que le pétainisme le pétainisme
c'est justement la paix plutôt la paix
dans la soumission que la guerre et
qu'est ce que c'est que le gaullisme
c'est le contraire c'est à dire plutôt
la guerre mais pour la liberté et encore
les pétainistes en vérité avait avait
plusieurs excuses d'abord on venait de
prendre une raclée monumentale
deuxièmement on avait le souvenir de la
boucherie de 14 troisièmement comme le
reconnaît le général de gaulle lui-même
et pétain et même laval essayé en vérité
de ruser avec les allemands c'est vous
le pétainiste vous comprenez c'est vous
le pacifiste mon cher mais oui mais oui
venir me l'aurait vous livre ce que vous
pensez que pétain c'est un une figure
historique en vérité vous savez bien que
c'est devenu une figure emblématique et
c'est la conséquence du pacifisme alors
et le pacifiste c'est vous ou pas là on
voit ici à le philosophe raphaël
enthoven totalement
sidéré alors la question c'est ce pétain
comme ça renvoyer c'est une arme la
rhétorique pour lui clouer le bec ça
c'est tout à fait ce qu'on appelle la
rétorsion rhétorique c'est à dire comme
on dit si vous voulez familièrement ses
suites il dit qu'il est qu'il m'a traité
d'oslo pas oublier qu'ils attaquent bien
de a l'origine dendooven c'est à dire
qu'il dit vous êtes pétainiste et donc
la référence
voilà il lui renvoie la balle et là
c'est très intéressant c est qu est-ce
qui rusent ici c'est vraiment et mourir
us sur un double plan les ruses
rhétoriquement renvoyant donc c'est vous
le pétainiste ce qui est toujours habile
à condition d'être d'être bon ce qui
l'est aussi ré tony et deuxièmement ils
rusent socratique mans je dirais ça
s'est vu ce procédé très fréquent chez
lui quand il dit qu'est ce que c'est que
le pétainisme ou qu'est ce que c'est que
la république ou qu'est ce que c'est que
la cre définisse final il redéfinit la
redéfinition rhétorique ou un peu rustre
hâtez vous savez qu'un abattement que je
vous dis qu'est-ce que et vous me dit
voilà je vous dis ça vous dit être
d'accord avec moi dont vous serez
d'accord avec les conclusions la
conclusion de pétainisme c'est un
pacifisme exactement donc vous êtes
coincé et il est très fort et le fait
systématiquement quasiment zemmour il
vous met d'accord sur une définition et
après vous êtes mort et après vous êtes
morts fin du mois sidéré en tout cas
sidéré ces derniers parlent attaque
alors on se demande alors c'est vrai
qu'ici beaucoup pétain et c'est vrai
alors ça rappelle évidemment pour le
coup là jean marie le pen qui en 2018
par exemple qui est pas si longtemps que
ça disait qu'il n'avait jamais considéré
le maréchal comme un traître ça rappelle
aussi que marine le pen elle s'est
toujours démarquée de ses polémiques et
segal bien gardé cité le maréchal pétain
et on se demande lui quel est l'intérêt
de venir cité comme ça que le maréchal
pétain aujourd'hui mais je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui lui permet d'une
part d'exister médiatiquement ça on l'a
vu c'est à dire qu'il fait ce qu'on
appelle en coups et les projecteurs sont
braqués sur lui et ça permet finalement
de l'exposé ça c'est la première raison
la deuxième raison je pense c'est qu'on
voit un peu sociologiquement que depuis
que marine le pen a pris la suite de son
père finalement elle a entrepris cette
entreprise de dédiabolisation alors la
dédiabolisation c'est beaucoup plus
ancien que marine le pen
il avait commencé déjà incité son père à
se dédiaboliser oui bien sûr mais même
avant ça il ya cette espèce de
dialectique diabolisation
dédiabolisation qui marque toute
l'histoire du rassemblement national et
avant lui du front national où on donne
des gages un peu de républicanisme de
démocratie et par ailleurs on fait des
espèces de provocation comme jean marie
le pen ont amené en relève justement
c'est de la provocation là il fait les
provocations de jean marie le pen en
citant pétillant définissant pétain bien
sûr puisque marine le pen depuis qu'elle
a pris la suite de son père finalement
certains considèrent qu'elle va trop
loin dans la dédiabolisation
mais en même temps comme elle a une
sorte de monopole de la diabolisation
finalement à travers son parti politique
est bien à la droite du rassemblement
national il ya rien finalement ce qui
fait que même les gens qui trouvent que
marine le pen est trop molle vont voter
pour marine le pen or là brusquement
eric zemmour intervient et refait du
jean marie le pen et qui fait que
brusquement il des portes un petit peu
marine le pen symboliquement vers la
gauche et qu'il ya un espace qui permet
non seulement à eric zemmour d'exister
mais en tout cas de toucher un électorat
et d'espèces de chiffon rouge quoi le
rappelle
pour marine le pen de façon un peu
atavique mais qu'il a avec cette
configuration de l'espace à la fois
idéologique et politique est bien
marginalise quelque peu marine deux pays
cela dit vous parlez de la
dédiabolisation
notre stagiaire aurélien tillier a fait
un petit montage ou 1-1 qu'on
al'impression qu'eric zemmour si mais
aussi le grand remplacement c'est
simplement une expression qui signifie
quoi d'ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'elle
a été inventé par l'onu vous souvenez et
que renault camille n'a fait que la
reprendre et que renaud camus cas ce
qu'il explique mélissa vous allez faire
croire à personne mais je vous assure
que c'est vrai moreland vouloir la
remise ration ce n'est pas être raciste
c'est considérer qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france qu' il y a que ça
pose un vrai problème d' équilibre
démographique et identitaire que
l'identité de la france est en danger et
donc c'est dire voilà on va renvoyer les
immigrés qui ne s'assimile pas c'est ce
qu'a fait la france pendant un siècle
vous n'êtes pas raciste mais c'est pas
du tout est raciste que de dire ça c'est
le général de gaulle n'était pas raciste
léon blum n'était pas raciste dans les
années 30 on renvoie des immigrés
italiens et polonais parce qu'ils sont
au chômage et qu'on estime qu'il
s'assimile pas et c'est la gauche qui
fait ça sont pas racistes c'est léon
blum voilà bref tous les biens de l'onu
et des ongles ou quoi il est des
diabolisation aussi c'est ce procédé
qu'on retrouve c'est totalement autre
chose et si oui quoi moi je pense que
c'est c'est totalement autre chose je
vais dire il ne renie absolument pas le
processus de l'art migration c'est à
dire finalement d'une part du grand
remplacement si ça vient de blum donc
c'est une manière de nan mais bloom n'a
jamais utilisé le terme rose migration
et puis le fait que la france renvoie
des immigrés dans leur pays d'origine
elle continue de le faire aujourd'hui
enfin je veux dire c'est une manière de
quoi leur d'embrouillés la rétorsion
encore de la rétorsion une fois la
rétorsion c'est à dire on m'accuse
d'être d'extrême droite alors que je
fais quelque chose que la gauche
elle-même a fait ou a dit mais est ce
que c'est vrai c'est une autre question
et si on veut plat entre guillemets
justement les cette brassée gens qui
trouvent que marine le pen s'est
déportée à gauche quel est l'intérêt de
citer ces références pour embrouiller
l'adversaire ou pour détruire la doxa un
de ceux qui est dit le discours
médiatico politique dominante par le
zemmour l'a1 donc pour montrer que ces
thèmes là ne sont pas
d'extrême droite c'est à dire que en
effet il ya eu une politique qu'on va
dire de fermeture des frontières sous la
gauche dans les années 30 ce qui
malheureusement je dois dire est
indiscutable c'est vrai même si c'est
pas léon blum
c'est là c'est là que oui c'est ça le
problème c'est que personne en face ne
connaît les références donc il a un peu
la main libre il a la manie - il faut
pas oublier aussi par exemple que le
front national de la jeunesse à une
époque avait des affiches en disant
jaurès aujourd'hui il voterait front
national donc il ya toujours cette
volonté de réappropriation finalement
qui va au delà des références de son
camp ce qui permet quelque part
effectivement vous l'avez dit une
certaine forme de dédiabolisation et là
ça lui permet finalement de puiser aux
sources de certains républicains
indiscutable et donc finalement de se
légitimer d'essayer de gagner une aura
au delà de son parti traditionnel ok je
comprends mais si je reviens c'est pas
la dédiabolisation telle que la pratique
et marine le pen en supprimant comme ça
des noms des références et une autre
juste une entreprise de légitimation
vous avez parfaitement raison alors vous
parliez christophe de bugs de ses
attaquants ça s'appelle des attaques ad
hominem procédé rhétorique je le
rappelle qui vise à décrédibiliser
l'adversaire en lui renvoyant ses
propres paroles à la figure et sans
répondre sur le fond mais sa technique
de débat est plus sophistiqué vous allez
nous expliquer à partir de cet exemple
qui je pense pose bien les choses avec
jean pierre chevènement vous savez je
suis de ceux de ses 5 % qui ont voté
pour vous en 2002 parce que justement ce
discours
me séduisait me séduisent et depuis
longtemps
et il répondait à ce que j'attendais ce
que je croyais comme comme réponse à la
crise que vivent et la france et je vais
vous avouer je vais développer mon idée
je ne le crois plus c'est à dire que je
pense que ce discours républicain est
désuet dépassé monsieur chevènement je
pense qu'une fois de plus vous vivez
dans les idéaux et que vous ne voyez pas
le réel il ya une très belle adresse e
mail j'en avais pas dans l'idéal et non
non moi je ne eric zemmour je ne vis pas
dans l'idéal parce que c'est vachement
et pourtant ça avait commencé quand même
gentiment j'ai voté pour vous là encore
grand talent rhétorique je parle d'un
strict point de vue
c'est intéressant démonter justement
qu'est-ce qui fait l'efficacité du
discours ce qu'on appelle la captation
de bienveillance c'est-à-dire gerber
partition de liens mais
c'est à dire je commence par vous faire
plein de compliments cher hélène risser
comme ça vous désarmés et puis d'un seul
coup jean bouin une vacherie et ça veut
dire que du coup on a perdu sa capacité
à secourir gardiennage le vieux lion qui
était d'ailleurs chevènement est très
prudent on le voit il attendit qu'est-ce
qui me prépare ça
sent pas bon donc là encore une
technique vous dites techniques
rhétorique très forte malheur est il
toujours si fort on s'est posé la
question on a visionné beaucoup
d'extraits pour préparer cette émission
et on s'est posé la question face à
laurent ruquier qu'il a pour le coup
connais bien eric zemmour et qui plutôt
que de répondre sur le terrain des idées
se met à l'attaqué lui aussi de façon
directe c'est toujours bien pour réponse
on vit dans un petit milieu dans une
bulle quand on lit votre livre on
comprend qui vit dans une bulle et dans
un petit milieu croyez moi et vous le
constaterez en iran au
restaurant tous les jours avec des
machines non non non non non si vous
voulez jouer pour tout le monde à paris
vase et ne rendent pas moi voulez je
vous montre mais voyez vous avez une
image des gens vous avez une image
fausse surpoids et surtout laisser mon
travail mais le déjeuner avec ces gens
c'est mon travail ça c'est un autre
débat à l'énoncé la vérité c'est comme
ça c'est du journalisme politique et
donc ne me faites pas croire qu'en même
temps vous connaissez la france et que
vous êtes moins si près des des français
alors j'écoute les témoignages les gens
viennent me parler ils viennent me
raconter parce que justement je le dis à
ceux qui viennent vous parlez sont ceux
qui ont les mêmes dangers que vous eric
non vous ne savez pas vous et où là on a
l'impression qu'il est davantage on va
dire à court d'arguments d'habitude et
puis avait quand même cette riposte
maladroite
paris tout le monde mange au restaurant
alors on se dit mais alors candidat
putatif à la présidentielle tout le
monde - le restaurant on a l'impression
que là il ne parle vraiment d'une bulle
est ce que l'ajustement sur ce terrain
plus concret il est pas moins bon dans
sa rhétorique à je dis pas qu'il est
extraordinaire mais franchement du connu
rhétorique laurent viguier quand même
marque une faiblesse kaki est
rédhibitoire dans ce labo cet échange a
oui ah bon il se met en colère c'est lui
qui sait ni qui s'énerve qui père qui
quand il dit ben voyons c'est une
manière de laisser
avec le livre avec ici il est quand même
très très très animée et regarder que
zemmour à face lui est très calme il est
toujours dangereux en rhétorique que sur
javier l'indignation dont vous trouvez
que surtout quand vous vous adressez à
quelqu'un que vous présentez comme un
extrémiste un petit commentaire lattier
mais finalement j'ai l'impression de
voir un petit peu le pen des années 80
c'est à dire que lorsque le pen a
commencé à émerger médiatiquement
c'était un peu une bête de plateaux télé
voulait allaient s'affronter aussi
absolument qu'ils aient des tas de
références sociologiques historiques
mais que les gens ne maîtrisait pas bien
et on n'avait pas encore appris le temps
de déconstruire tous ces discours et qui
finalement plonger les gens et ses
interlocuteurs dans une forme de
sidération et j'ai l'impression que là
avec zemmour on est un peu retourné dans
cet état de jean marie le pen des années
80 de son émergence on n'avait pas prêt
encore la mesure du personnage de ce
qu'il représentait et où il
effectivement il il sidérait tout le
monde on l'avait battu au sort n'est pas
encore des conspirateurs nous on essaye
de déconstruire le discours avec un
dernier ingrédient christophe de 22 vous
pas rien dans ce petit manuel de
déconstruction du discours
j'ai trouvé un extrait qui l'illustrent
je suis là je donne extraits vous vous
expliquerez un extrait de son livre où
il présente une france dans laquelle les
noms gaulois refuserait de s'intégrer en
raison dans l'inconscient collectif qui
nous dirigent dit il celui de ces
populations musulmanes et de coloniser
l'ancien colonisateur de dominer
l'infidèle au nom d'allah la supplie de
la rhétorique c'est de la psychanalyse
la solution collectif qui est de le
dominer c'est ce que j'appelle le saut
zemmourien c'est à dire le moment de
rupture chez zemmour qui est toujours
difficile à détecter et vous avez vous
avez parlé à plusieurs reprises c'est à
dire le moment où je travaille à verser
ce que c'est bon dans une problématique
est beaucoup plus là on était typique de
l'extrême droite avec cet inconscient
collectif des peuples et qui le coin
alors qu'il a c'est le moment où on va
pas dire dérapages horreur de ce mot
mais cette année elle s'est prêtée à
l'autre un projet secret consacré
associant inconscient oui c'est le
second appel de bienne d'intentionnalité
le complotisme surtout l'essentialisme
d'essentialisme négative c'est-à-dire
les populations musulmanes n'aurait que
ça en tête et c'est ce que j'appelle le
moment de rupture zemmourien et vous qui
se produit souvent quand il est lui
aussi un peu énervé et où il va tollé
dans son livre un leader solide mais
peut il peut s'énerver dans services en
ti
et en lots sur le plateau on le voit et
c'est là où généralement il voir des
ennuis avec la justice ou une
association quelle qu'elle soit mais je
sens si vous voulez que si on veut des
construire son discours c'est là qu'il
faut attaquer tout bon et bien merci
beaucoup christophe de rhodes pour ses
analyses on va voir maintenant qui
promeut ce discours d'eric zemmour
lequel bénéficie d'une vraie communauté
sur les réseaux sociaux en son sein de
nombreux jeunes qui se sont baptisés
génération z et keith immortalise en
train de coller des affiches d'eric
zemmour président ils sont bien en
campagne d affiches qu'on retrouve à
grenoble avec l'uci qui fait le voeu de
la victoire est aussi en charente sous
le hashtag stop censure qui explique ce
jeune militant aussi écouter on est ici
pour le soutenir et en le soutenant lui
en soutien à la liberté d'expression
liberté de s'exprimer on combat
également le complot médiatique qui est
en train de se mettre en place contre
monsieur zemmour ces procès politique
qui arrive juste au moment
présidentielle ça c'était pour la forme
classique et propre sur soi maintenant
celle de la jeune tic toc euse au code
de bimbo
bref il y à un assaut de jeunes
militants zemmourien sur les réseaux
sociaux mais avec quel impact dites-nous
tout véronique vous qui avez le don de
faire parler les hashtag on va dire que
c'était pas que pour monsieur zemmour
globalement ce sont les jeunes qui se
sont plutôt lancer dans la campagne en
tout cas qui se sont lancés dans la
conquête plus haut et les candidats y
voit là les candidats c'est vrai aussi
pour monsieur macron c'est vrai pour
tout le monde et donc c'est plus
crédible quand c'est une jeune femme qui
utilise des codes sur tik tok comme ça
que si c'était monsieur zemmour qui
faisait semaine tout qu'est le brillant
ça à tout ça est ce que ça s'apprend au
delà de cette petite sphère de jeunes
militants alors on obligé de prendre un
peu de recul et de se rappeler que quand
on est en campagne à plusieurs temps est
le premier temps c'est le temps de la
curiosité c'est à dire est-ce que vous
en tant que candidat ou par son public
vous susciter de la curiosité pour le
faire là on va regarder avec un outil
assez simple qui est google trend
setters on va regarder le nombre de gens
qui vont se poser la question et qui
cherchent des informations sur un
candidat et je vois qu'il y en a
beaucoup plus que pour marine le pen
valérie pécresse et xavier bertrand
exactement après la curiosité on à
l'intérêt c'est pas la même chose
curiosité je me renseigne sur la
personne intérêt est ce qu'on parle de
lui et donc là de nouveau on a gardé les
mêmes comment vous dire c'est assez
flagrant on s'intéresse à monsieur
zemmour bien plus que tous les autres
voilà donc on s'y intéresse malgré ce
que tous ces gens le soutiennent
véronique est évidemment non tout le
monde ne le soutient pas mais c'est
intéressant surtout en début de campagne
de regarder quelle est la proportion
vous allez me dire 65 % des gens qui
parlent de lui sont des opposants non
c'est
beaucoup par rapport aux autres c'est
beaucoup moins ce qui est intéressant
c'est le bleu et qui est assez important
donc les soutiens qu'ils sont les
soutiens affichés donc les gens qui
mettent dans leur bio je suis pour
débourser
1000 à la génération z les gens qui
s'expriment en reprenant des expressions
positives sur ce qu'il dit c'est
relativement important à ce stade là et
c'est d'autant plus intéressant qu'en
fait quand on regarde la motivation un
démo qui est souvent repris c'est la
notion d'authenticité
pourquoi parce qu'en fait les gens ils
ont l'impression que eric zemmour a
quelque chose d'authentiqué je sais vous
êtes en train de lire dans un pourquoi
dit elle ça non ce qu'ils appellent
l'authenticité c'est qu'il ya une forme
de cohérence sur ce qu'il dit depuis
toujours qu'en fait il est constant que
ils ne changent pas d'avis et donc il
est authentique et sincère et ça ça me
mobilise aussi ça aide pour gagner
d'autres sphères que votre sphère
naturelles qui sont donc les gens qui
spontanément voilà ont mis dans leur bio
ils sont depuis le début pour vous petit
à petit ça peut vous aider à partager
des informations sans dire encore que
vous êtes totalement soutien voilà ce
qu'il veut continuer au moins les dix
qui pensent comme moi il est sincère
c'est déjà un bon pas et c'est un levier
qui permet d'utiliser en ce début de
campagne c'est une qualité qui en son
temps on reconnaissait à jean marie le
pen normalement et alors on sait sylvain
crépon que l'extrême droite est très
présente depuis longtemps sur les
réseaux sociaux en raison notamment de
la défiance de ses militants qu'ils
habitent des médias classiques ils
préfèrent converser entre sur les
réseaux sociaux du coup est ce que ce
que véronique vient de dire vous semble
surprenant ou pas au vie justement de
cette sphère alors certains diront c'est
la fachosphère qui est sur les
résolutions qui suit zemmour non c'est
pas que ça vous dit nancy dans les dents
les soutiens là c'est pas que ça c'est
parce que ça qu'en dites vous ben je
pense que vous avez raison déjà de dire
que tout de suite les partis
nationalistes d'extrême droite ou qui se
sentent marginaux tout de suite investi
internet parce qu'ils voyaient là
effectivement un moyen 2 diffusez eux
mêmes leurs idées sans qu'il y ait
forcément un prisme qui soient négatifs
le front national a été le premier parti
à se doter d'un site internet en france
donc c'est quand même assez important de
le souligner pour ces raisons là après
je pense qu'il faut faire un petit peu
attention à tout ce qu'on voit donc sur
ces images de collage n'affiche et c'est
bon ça tous les partis tous les petits
groupuscules peuvent se donner comme sa
une une image assez emblématique en les
mettant sur les réseaux sociaux plus
avec
zemmour là vous savez tout de suite que
ça va être repris que ça va être diffusé
que vous allez pouvoir avoir une
visibilité
donc j'ai envie dire je pense que je
resterai encore prudent sur la caisse de
résonance que ce type de stratégie peut
avoir mais en tout cas le fait qu'on en
parle ici ça montre déjà qu'il y en ait
pas qui sinon
les choses à leur juste place
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci
marie lebon aurélien tillier et laurent
ferré qui est géré trouvera en salle de
montage en europe le travail aujourd'hui
la curiosité du férié en tu tapes dans
google et puis qui est seymour et je
regarde ce qui a été fait après
l'intérêt c'est que tu parles de la
personne en bien en mal an ne truque sur
l'année ces trucs donc à une action de 6
à 14 ans tu prends de ton temps pour
raconter quelque chose en plus